alors non je demande si on sait donc
consacrer à votre compagne
ex-compagne l'etv way qui nous a quittés
au mois de septembre 2000 et qui a été
une pionnière du hip hop qui était
danseuse graffiti artistes kaka était là
durant toute l'aventuré une tnt
qui d'abord avait vraiment une âme pure
c'était quelqu'un qui était vrai et
c'est vrai et c'est vrai que je pense
qu'un homme quand il a une femme à ses
côtés comme ça il fait des choses et
réalise il crée
à près de 10 ce qui est déjà fait des
mécontents ouais ça va ça marche bien
premier album solo c'est bien que ça se
vende non mais c'est cool hein ça montre
qu'il ya des gens qui suivent un peu
aussi et pas simplement avec le groupe
mais qu'ils adhèrent aussi un univers
simple plaisir alors ce dernier round
c'est un cd d'un type d'un type nouveau
il ya d'abord de la vidéo ensuite il ya
des données informatiques vous êtes le
premier à faire ça en europe ou encore
aux états unis à une personne qui l'a
fait avant et les maisons de disques les
majors avaient tendance à être frileuse
sur ce genre de support parce que savoir
qu'il peut y avoir des projets nous on a
bien étudié l'histoire et apparemment il
n'y a pas plus de rejet que pour un cd
classique donc c'est un cd où il ya le
son d'un côté et des images de l'autre
côté plus de l'interactivité voilà
c'était française qui fait ça que
j'appelle digital vallée c'est ça bravo
ne serais pas étonné qu'on y est